hey before you watch this video you
should know on september 28th
the michael knowles show will be moving
from the daily wire youtube channel
to the michael knowles show youtube
channel because that only makes sense
doesn't it
you can get a link in the description
below head on over there we're going to
have obviously the show exclusively
at the michael knowles show channel but
we will also have new breakout content
interviews
all that kind of fun stuff so head on
over there to the michael show youtube
channel
ring the bell and never miss a video i
go away for one week
one week and i come back to pedo movies
on hollywood's biggest platform
and the town literally burning to the
ground ash
covering my front steps there is a lot
to catch up on
before the well-deserved fire and
brimstone takes us all out
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
good to be back everybody i had a great
time in utah i missed you all very much
also have to come i know it's been a
little while it's been a full
week but i have to get to my favorite
comment from the last show from david
winoker
political science the only science that
ignores all the rules of science
like logical thought and analysis of
cause and effect that is true
political science does ignore all the
rules of science it also ignores all the
rules of politics
and we'll get to that a little bit later
also got to thank our friends over at
ring you know ring you know why i love
ring you can tell look i'm here away
from my home i'm back in washington dc
we've got some fun stuff planned over
the next few days and when i'm away from
home i'm so glad
that i can trust ring it makes
neighborhoods safer
makes your home safer let you keep an
eye on your home from anywhere whether
you're at the office whether you're in
the bedroom whether you're
all the way across the country in
washington dc it's
just wonderful sweet little elise is a
good shot but i want to know that she
is safe and i can do that with ring it's
got security products for every corner
of your house inside and out obviously
you know about the ring video doorbell
they got a lot of other great stuff too
the chime pro right now you can get a
special offer on the ring
welcome kit at ring.com
knowles you know this is this is what i
give to my friends as a housewarming
gift
and they still love it and part of the
reason i give it to them by the way not
just because it's so great but because
it's also inexpensive so i look like a
really cool guy and give them a great
product
you can get that welcome kit it's got
rings video doorbell 3 and shine pro the
perfect way to start your ring
experience
plus it's got two-day free shipping go
to ring.com
knowles what's that at url ring.com
knowles head on over check it out now
i had a great time in utah okay i was
having i haven't taken a vacation since
my honeymoon
and i was so excited to go and relax we
were
sweet little lisa and me and we were
there with a couple of friends and i was
having a great time
until ben ruined it i did not do any
work i barely
tweeted i didn't but ben calls me so i
say okay i got to pick up the phone hey
ben what's going on
he says hey knowles uh you got to watch
cuties
cuties why i have to watch cuties okay
he made me watch it because obviously
it's the hottest topic
that anybody it's not hot it's not a hot
don't please don't
misconstrue what i'm saying but it is a
hot topic and it's a hot political issue
there are now calls for investigations
of it
so he said basically you're a cultural
commentator i want your take
on what this is i said i don't want to
watch this degenerate filth
and that's the question right is cutie's
degenerate filth
or is it being misinterpreted like
netflix is saying that it is now i knew
from the beginning that it was
degenerate filth
because it's a french movie and all
french film
is degenerate filth so i kind of knew
that it was going to be like that
uh going in i then pull up my netflix
and i see
the first movie that they're promoting
is cuties this movie about 11 year olds
twerking
and being sexualized that's the first
movie the second movie
lucifer all right a little on the nose
here hollywood
thought we're not in for a great trip
then we start watching the movie it's me
sweet little lisa my two friends
sitting there on the other couch my
friend's fiance
storms out of the room crying because of
how creepy the movie was
with the sexualizing shots of young
girls
netflix defends it the left right now
largely defending this movie
saying that the right is completely
misconstruing it they didn't see it they
barely watched the trailer
well i saw it so i can give you an
honest take but this is what netflix
says
cuties is a social commentary against
the sexualization of young children
it's an award-winning film and a
powerful story about the pressure young
girls face on social media
and from society more generally growing
up and we'd encourage anyone who cares
about these important
issues to watch the movie and the thing
about it is
that description is actually correct
sort of sort of but it misses
the most important point the message of
the movie
could be interpreted could be doesn't
need to be interpreted but could be
interpreted as
against the sexualization of young girls
the the movie is about this young girl
who's from a muslim family
and the film basically says that the
muslims are sexualized young girls too
by marrying them off very young
but then western degenerate decadent
france is is also sexualizing young
girls with twerking and
you know rap music and whatever all kind
of modern culture
and it sort of opposes that you know it
it shows some of the pitfalls of that it
could also be interpreted
as saying that young girls need to
explore their sexuality and sometimes
they go too far
but they need to explore it anyway so
i'm not even i'm not even saying
that it it totally does what netflix is
saying in the message
but let's just for argument's sake let's
just say that is the message of the
movie
the problem is that in presenting that
message
the movie sexualizes and exploits
the 11 year old girls it does the thing
that it says that it's against it would
be like having a movie
about how terrible it is to torture
animals and then
for an hour and a half of the movie it's
people literally torturing animals and
stomping on them and
punching them and throwing them against
the wall and then at the end of the
movie it says but maybe it's bad to
torture animals
say okay well did you have to torture
all the animals to tell me how bad it is
to torture animals
no and that's what's going on in the
movie because the movie doesn't star 16
year old girls
playing 11 year old girls or 18 year old
girls playing 11 year old girls or 20
year old right
you could imagine a world in hollywood
does this all the time
where you get an older actor or actress
to play a younger actor actress
but they didn't do that here it's
actually 11 year old girls
with gratuitous exploitative close-up
shots
of their various body parts i mean there
are parts of this movie
that are genuinely nauseating and
they're needless
you do not need those shots to convey
the message that netflix is saying
that the movie is portraying a part of
netflix's defenses they said okay well
the poster was a little exploitative
but the movie is not that way the post
is from the movie the poster is a shot
from the movie more or less
it's a shot from the end of the movie it
doesn't convey the message necessarily
of the movie but it is part of the movie
so it is exploitative people are saying
it's child pornography i mean i guess
it's i guess it's not technically child
pornography because
the girls aren't naked or i don't know i
mean what is what is pornography right
is
a famous uh supreme court justice said i
can't define it but i know it when i see
it
at the very least though at the very
least we should all be able to agree to
agree
this is sexually exploitative of
children of little girls and it has no
place
in a decent society i guess it has a
place in france but it has no place
in a decent society so what are we to do
about this
don't forget netflix is super duper
left-wing 98
of the time that netflix employees
donate to politicians
they donate to democrats and this is not
some
new thing on the left this is not some
fantasy imagined by the right the left
has been sexualizing children
for at this point 80 years 80 or 90
years
this began we talked actually a little
bit about this on the show the week
before i took my vacation
which is that you have these theorists
these weird left-wing theorists
in beginning in the 30s talking about
how we need to sexualize young kids
there was this guy wilhelm reich very
popular theorist for the left
who said that the reason and cause of
war and
famine and disease and cancer was the
people weren't having enough orgasms
seriously you can read about this
he said he had discovered the life force
of the universe the orgones
he developed a box called the orgone
accumulator it's just a wooden box
woody allen parodied it as the
orgasmatron and there were very
prominent leftists who had
the orgasmatron box jd salinger guy
wrote catcher in the rye norman mailer
considered one of the great geniuses of
the left in the 20th century they all
had this weird orgasm box
it wasn't just this weirdo wilhelm reich
it goes all the way up through the 60s
and 70s in bernie sanders
bernie sanders who made a good play for
the presidency even in 2020
he wrote very creepy essays in the 1960s
and 1970s about how we have to sexualize
children
based on righteous theories because
righteous theories is that sexual
repression
is why we have all these evils in the
world and when are you most sexually
repressed when you're a child
so we need to allow children to explore
their sexuality and molest one another
bernie sanders wrote essays explicitly
about this okay
it's been building on the left for a
long time which is why they are
normalizing this kind of stuff with the
pederasty bill that we just saw in
california also the week before i went
away
and now with cuties so what do we do
about this are we now hypocrites on the
issue of free speech
because we don't like this creepy
exploitative movie
i don't think so right now senator ted
cruz someone i'm visiting in washington
dc
so that we can film more episodes of our
podcast verdict is calling for an
investigation into netflix for promoting
cuties he's not the only politician
doing that many others are as well
this brings i think this is very good
that's a good political point this
brings up a larger philosophical point
which is
we need to get more precise about the
term free speech
you're going to see a lot of squishy
concert conservatives quote unquote
who are defending cuties on the grounds
of free speech and we should be totally
clear about this
and have some basic historical
understanding
the founding fathers would have jailed
the people who produced cuties
at least i think some of the founding
fathers would have done more than jail
them
the founding fathers and from for most
of the people in our country's history
would have had no thought that cuties
is somehow protected by the first
amendment that it's protected
free speech what is what do we mean by
free speech the left just backed us into
a corner here
because we are now we conservatives are
now the ones saying that any
type of speech is protected speech which
is simply not true in american history
we're saying that we're totally opposed
to any kind of standards on speech
which has never been true not just in
this country it's never been true
anywhere
all societies at all times in all places
throughout history
have had and have enforced standards
about speech
and especially in this country the
question is
what are the standards well there are
plenty of things that have never been
considered protected speech in this
country beyond cuties we'll get to that
one second first got to thank our
friends
over at car shield you know me i don't
know a whole lot about cars
okay i tried to i tried to become a
little more masculine over
my vacation in utah took in a little bit
of fly fishing
did some activities outdoors you know i
still don't know anything about cars and
courses are very complicated these days
computer systems and cars are the new
normal and you i can barely change my
oil you think that i can work on a
computer system
no and you can't fix these new features
yourself and they're always
extraordinarily expensive
and then you find yourself out if the
car breaks down you can't do anything
about it that's why i love
car shield car shield has affordable
production plans that can save you
thousands of dollars for a covered
repair and kill including computers
gps electronics more
give the car shield the thing i love
about them there are a lot of options
out there
car shield gives you options that other
companies won't
you get to choose your favorite mechanic
or your favorite dealership you get to
have them do the work and car shield
will take care of the rest they offer
complimentary 24 7
roadside assistance and a rental car
while yours is being fixed
car shield has helped over 1 million
customers go
use them for as low as 99 a month you
can protect yourself from surprises
and save thousands of dollars for a
covered repair call 800
car 6000 and mention code knowles or
visit carshield.com and use code knowles
to save 10 percent that is car
shield.com code knowles
a deductible may apply
in american history obscenity has never
been considered protected
speech it is still not it depends where
you are but still
in some places it's not considered
protected speech pornography same thing
was never considered protected
speech we we permitted it in some cases
but we also have heavy restrictions on
it don't forget during the george w bush
administration at the end of the george
w bush administration
we jailed a pornographer simply for
being so obscene okay this is not
some anachronism this is not some
anti-american idea
it's been going on for the entirety of
our country including
as recently as two presidents ago
sedition not protected speech you cannot
be seditious
or you can at least be prosecuted for
being seditious threats
are not considered protected speech okay
we have broad and wonderful
free speech protections in this country
but we've got to get
specific the brilliance of political
correctness
nobody talks about this but it's the
genius of the whole thing
the brilliance of political correctness
is that it backed conservatives into a
lose-lose situation we all know that
political correctness which the left has
used to gain a lot of power in the last
several decades more than several
decades
is this speech code but but the thing
about it is it's kind of an
anti-speech code speech code it's a
speech code designed to
destroy all of the previous standards we
had on speech
on issues of sex on issues of obscenity
on issues of blasphemy on issues of all
these sorts of things
it's a it's a an anti-speech code speech
code and so it puts us in a tough
position
because if if conservatives oppose
political correctness which we should
then we've either got to come out
against speech codes in general
which is kind of what they wanted in the
first place
or we look like hypocrites and we've
gotten we've got to embrace their speech
code which would be terrible as well
it said damned if you do damned if you
don't situation
we've we've got to be much more specific
we use a lot of slogans in this country
we're using a lot of slogans these days
with black lives matter all lives matter
all that kind of stuff which we'll get
to later
but we need to be more specific what do
those things
mean what kind of speech is not
protected libel is not protected and the
trump campaign
is zeroing in on this right now so while
i was away there was this
absolutely preposterous stupid
irresponsible fraudulent atlantic story
that was published it was written by the
editor-in-chief of the atlantic
based on four anonymous sources saying
that donald trump denigrated
fallen u.s soldiers that sounds about
right right because the media they
haven't lied to you for the past four
years and we know trump hates the
military right
the guy who stoops down and picks up a
marine's hat the guy who runs his whole
campaign about how much he loves the
military he probably hates the military
right well sure the atlantic
confirmed it with four anonymous sources
and then
unbelie a fox news reporter came out and
said that she
confirmed the report by talking to an
anonymous source which is by the way
not possible i'm not saying it's not
possible because she didn't talk to
someone i'm saying it's not possible
because
you cannot confirm an anonymous report
story
with an anonymous source like
ontologically you cannot do that that is
not
not possible so absolutely irresponsible
stuff there
by the way 21 people have gone on the
record
to contradict this report that was
written by a bunch of anonymous sources
then within one day of this report joe
biden puts up an ad about it
it was within like 12 hours was there
some collusion going on perhaps was this
a setup i don't know it kind of looks
that way
here's the biden ad
you see it in a cemetery why should i go
to that cemetery
it's filled with losers that's what
trump allegedly said about a military
cemetery
it's like written cartoonishly with some
hollywood reject writer
suckers allegedly says that
mean old mr trump we are not going to
support that loser's funeral
talking about uh john mccain i suppose
that one he might have said not because
he didn't like the troops but because
trump
and john mccain famously did not get
along i don't get it
trump says what was in it for them yeah
yeah that's right because trump's such
an idiot right so he doesn't understand
the role of the military in civic life
if you don't respect
our troops you cannot lead them
that's what biden is saying here at the
end of this joe biden ad so vote for
biden that's the point
it was ready to go i wonder if they got
advanced notice of that probably they
did
anyway now jenna ellis friend of the
show
you've certainly seen her on this show
and when i when i fill in on radio for
ben
she emailed the tech firms she's now
trump's legal counsel
and she instructed the big tech firms to
use their so-called fact checkers
to take down this ridiculous joe biden
ad based on absolutely nothing
this libelous ad based on
nothing let's not forget libel is not
protected speech and does
does this add rise to the level of libel
well there's no evidence for it we can
at least say that
and also this is again on the kind of
broader philosophical
point that conservatives need to
recognize because we need to deal in the
realities of our world
there is no such thing as free speech
when your political opponents
do not recognize free speech there's no
such thing
you are not able to live in a regime of
free speech
when half of the country and a lot and
most of the people in power
refuse to play by those rules then
you're just a sucker then you talk about
the word sucker then you are a sucker
because you're playing by a set of rules
that your opponents will not play by
so you will be held to standards that
they will not be held to
so what rules do we play by there's a
new report another i suppose anonymous
report but
this one i think we should believe and
for for a reason which i'll get to in a
second
there's a report that democrats if they
take the senate and they get a lot of
power in the 20 2020 election
they will move to kill the filibuster
okay and this report comes from nbc news
the reason i believe this report is
because
nbc news is on the same side of the
political aisle as the democrats who are
going to do this thing so i think
they've got good sources here and i
think they're leaking it for a reason
they're going to kill the filibuster now
what is the filibuster filibuster is
basically this rule that any member of
the senate can get up and talk for a
really really long time
and slow down or stop legislation and so
you need
not just a simple majority of the senate
to get something through but
very often you need 60 votes okay and
this has been a treasured part of the
senate for a long time
and they they said this is according to
nbc
the senate can nuke the filibuster with
a simple majority vote but it would set
an irreversible precedent
the idea of doing so was never
entertained in obama's presidency
and it will be a heavy lift to stitch
together the 50 votes necessary to do so
but that's bs that's just a lie from nbc
news
the democrats already nuked a lot of the
filibuster
during obama's presidency because they
wanted to get more of obama's executive
and judicial appointees through
and the republicans were holding it up
so they just nuked the filibuster
and by the way when they did that mitch
mcconnell warned them that it was a
horrible idea and they were going to
come to regret it
very quickly here's mr cocaine himself
once again senate democrats are
threatening to break the rules of the
senate
break the rules of the senate in order
to change the rules of the senate
and over what over what
over a court that doesn't even have
enough work to do the majority leader
promised
he promised over
and over again that he wouldn't break
the rules of the senate in order to
change them
if you want to play games set yet
another
precedent that you'll no doubt come to
regret
say to my friends on the other side of
the aisle you'll regret this and you may
regret it a lot sooner than you think
you may regret it a lot sooner than you
think so what does this mean for
republicans what should we do
because i think a lot of republicans
myself included like the filibuster it
makes the senate more deliberative it
slows things down i really like it
but that's not enough liking it is not
enough okay
what this means is that even though we
like the filibuster
senate republicans should probably get
rid of it especially if we win big in
november then then we should definitely
get rid of it even though we like it
why because we're not going to get a
cookie we're not going to get
a special prize for preserving this
wonderful rule that we all really like
when our opponents are not going to
preserve it they're telling us to our
faces
that they're not going to preserve it so
they're going to use it to ram through
their agenda but we're supposed to play
by a different set of rules
that ain't how politics is supposed to
work that's not how winning politics
works okay
also it's not as though the filibuster
is some part of the constitution
okay the filibuster has only been even
theoretically possible since i think
1806 is it yeah they said the senate
changed a rule
and it's been possible since then it was
never used not even once
until 1837 then it was barely used after
that until the 1970s some senate rules
changed it around made it a more a
little stronger
made it a little a little more uh in use
okay i like it and it makes the senate
more deliberative
we're not in a deliberative time and we
need to recognize those rules it's the
same thing with the speech
it's the same thing with the slogans so
it's the same thing with
with uh i mean if you if you're looking
at this the speech
it's the same the same thing with cuties
right or
what what some of the conservatives the
liberal conservatives say
is well look if we if we admonish cuties
and tell netflix to take cuties down
well then maybe they'll take down the
passion of the christ
uh no i don't think so i think i don't
think those are comparable i think we
can make
judgments here along the way by the way
they're already taking things down
they're taking down cop shows cop
cop shows are not going to be allowed on
streaming platforms anymore they're
taking down gone with the wind one of
the greatest films ever made
but we're supposed to keep up cuties
this is what the conservatives do
the liberal conservatives do this they
are always so nervous about some
hypothetical abstract world if we ever
exercise any power whatsoever
they miss the fact that the left is
already exercising that power against us
in the real world but we're not we're
not supposed to fight back
okay and they're they're trying to do it
now to get a complete lock
on virtually every election in the
country and it has to do with their
creepy obsession with kids we'll get to
that one second first got to thank our
friends
over at express vpn have you ever
wondered
why internet access is so much cheaper
these days i don't know if you remember
back when i was but a wee lad in the
1990s
so expensive and it was still expensive
for a long time but now it's like 30 40
bucks a month
why is that it's because internet
service providers like comcast or at t
are not just making money on the
subscription fees they're also making
money
by spying on you and your internet
activity and using that data and selling
that data against you that's why it's so
cheap there's no such thing as a free
lunch
i think people of our persuasion tend to
understand that
so what's the best way to make sure that
100 of your data is encrypted
so that you don't get spied on you don't
you don't get your data sold
you need to use expressvpn i love
expressvpn i got expressvpn on my
computer i got expressvpn on my phone
the idea now of of going on the internet
without a vpn is sort of unthinkable and
i know you think it's like oh it's not a
big deal they're not for my data
they are and i know it's vpn it sounds
like kind of a high-tech thing so you're
like i don't know if it really matters
it does it does a lot of bad actors are
out there trying to get your data you've
got to use a vpn okay by the way it's
not even just for your phone or computer
works on all your devices works on
tablets smart tvs even your router so
your whole family
can always stay protected they got a
great router i highly recommend it your
data is your business
protect it at expressvpn.com michael
that is
expressvpn.com michael to get three
extra months of expressvpn protection
for free
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l
go on check it out learn more and
protect yourself
how else is the left trying to
completely dominate politics well
they are they are looking again at kids
creepy and this time it's not just to
sexualize them
in weird french movies it is to
allow them to vote the left has for a
long time wanted kids to vote now in san
francisco
they are trying to let 16 year olds vote
san franciscans
rejected a similar proposal in 2016 but
they only
they only lost that by two points and
you know what the left does they just
try try try again
until they get their way this is not
just some lunatics out in san francisco
well i guess it is lunatics in san
francisco but even lunatic san
franciscans at the national level
nancy pelosi supports this she told us
so years ago
i myself personally am not speaking for
my caucus
i myself have always been for lowering
the vote the voting age to 16.
i think it's really important to capture
kids when they're in high school when
they're
interested in all of this when they're
learning about government
to be able to vote why are they doing
this why do they want 16 year olds to
vote
is it because 16 year olds are so mature
no at this point these days i don't
think 60 year olds are very mature
i think people are getting much more
immature even as the population gets
older
so i i don't think it's for that reason
i think it's for purely partisan reasons
young people vote for democrats
one of the people pushing for this new
ballot initiative it basically confirms
the purely partisan basis here crystal
chan who's an organizer for
uh 1 16 vote 16 sf says
i really think that vote 16 will help
youth of color in san francisco
establish the habit of voting in an
earlier age and really provide them with
the support
and resources that they need to continue
building on that habit as they grow
older notice that you say
vote 16 this is about age why is this
organizer of the project
bringing race into it it's going to help
youth of color what about youth of
whiteness what about youth of
translucency are they is not going to
help them vote
no the reason that they're focusing on
the young voters is the same reason that
they're focusing on
black voters and some other racial
minorities is because
the democrats think they have a lock on
that vote so if they can get more of
those
those groups to vote then they're going
to win more of the elections
this is a purely naked
partisan move right but on the
philosophical level
there's there's another issue here it's
based on a false understanding of human
nature
that the left has been pushing for a
long time
the the kind of traditional
understanding of human nature is that
man is born a slave to his passions
little babies can't do very much on
their own
and little children are monsters think
lord of the flies right
little children are little tyrants and
they don't know how to behave themselves
and they're constantly following their
appetites and they always stuff
themselves full of cookies
and they drink too much soda and they
get a stomachache and they need to be
educated
into controlling themselves and
understanding their freedom and only
once they're educated
in the best sort of freedom and civic
traditions
then can they participate in the civil
society
what the left tells you is the opposite
what the left tells you is and and
in some ways liberalism broadly tells
you is that people are born free
they're born free and perfect in a
beautiful blank slate and they're
totally free and
there's no such thing as broken human
nature there's no such thing as the fall
they're
perfect you know but then society man
that damn society
it ruins them and william rice and
bernie sanders would say they just they
they're sexually repressed and you know
they don't have enough orgasms
and they don't and they need they need
orgone accumulators in their room
whatever kind of crazy stuff bernie
sanders was saying in the 60s and 70s
and leftists obviously are still pushing
today
society makes them imperfect society
and if you just fixed those issues from
the
social engineering level you know more
poverty programs or something
and at the personal and even sexual
level from this anti-repression and the
weird boxes that norman mailer and
william wright were pushing
then we would have a perfect society
basically that politics
and social engineering has the ability
as long as we make politics totally
personally even all the way down to the
sexual level
has the ability to perfect society and
if you're trying to
to do that if you're looking for the
most pure wonderful put together people
you don't look to the wisdom of the ages
you don't look to older people who've
matured and educated themselves
you look to children that's the
philosophical basis here it's based on
this false
understanding of human nature of course
actual wisdom does not come from
children
or from pedophiles it doesn't come from
either of those
despite our culture's uh
misunderstanding today
actual wisdom tends to come from older
people there's a great story that just
came out
from this guy lawrence brooks he is the
oldest living world war
ii veteran he just turned 111 years old
born
in 1909.
okay this guy says he has the secret to
life lawrence brooks says secret to life
is
serve god and be nice to people
so simple so simple and yet we've
completely forgotten that and both sides
of that are really important
because if you just say be nice to
people i guess that's what the left says
but their niceness isn't all that
nice it isn't kind it isn't generous
it's just saying oh we all need to just
be tolerant with a capital t and just
kind of get along and we don't care
about truth and we don't care about
purpose and we don't care about any
injustice or anything we're just going
to be really nice
no you got to serve god first and be
nice to people because you can't serve
god
without being charitable and you so you
don't you don't want to just be a jerk
curmudgeon all the time you need to be
charitable but you also need to be
courageous
you also need to be just you also need
to be honest okay
very good wisdom for life if i had my
druthers that guy
lawrence brooks would pretty much be the
only guy to vote i don't even know if
he's a demo i don't think he's a
democrat
but i'd probably i'd probably say that
guy should vote right because he has
some wisdom and we should
we should encourage people who have
wisdom to share it with the rest of us
in our society
speaking of people who are almost as old
as lawrence brooks
but who unfortunately don't have any
wisdom joe biden
this is a weird story people were
tweeting this to me even on my vacation
i had to see it because i thought i was
living in a kind of bizarro
world universe you know over my vacation
i didn't shave
so i had like a kind of little goatee
and then i saw my evil twin
he was the one without the goatee but
and i was the one with the goatee but it
was my evil
twin tj ducklow joe biden's
national press secretary went on fox
news when on brett baird's show and was
asked specifically
what joe biden would have done
differently on coronavirus he had no
answer
the vice president was not against the
travel ban first of all second of all
let's remember and it wasn't uh brett
let's remember an important distinction
donald trump was the president of the
united states it was on donald trump i'm
asking you
joe biden donald trump it was on donald
trump he would
take action to actually protect the
american people he closed the joke
traveled joe biden wrote an op-ed in usa
today in january warning that the threat
was coming
joe biden said in february that donald
trump should get people on the ground
in china what did what did donald trump
do donald trump was praising china
donald trump was praising president xi's
response saying that they had it under
control
when clearly he knew as we now know from
bob woodward they did not have it under
control he should have been protecting
the american people he should have been
putting real plans in place so let me
just clarify
confront this incredibly dangerous
understand let me just clarify you're
saying that joe biden
was for closing down travel from china
when the president did it
uh joe biden has been clear and i can
send you the fact checks if they're
helpful
brad joe biden has been clear that he
was not against that travel ban but he
was for it
joe biden has been clear about this
brett again i can send i can send you
the fact checks
if they're helpful this has been fact
checked into oblivion
it only got worse from there you see he
can't give an answer he just talks about
the fact checks
people people did point out at this
point that mr ducklow bears a striking
resemblance to me they were asking if he
was
me you know i if i and i guess i just
owe the people an explanation
i'll just come i'll just come clean well
you all thought i was on vacation
i i became joe biden's national press
secretary
um i i figured right now that's that's
the only way i can get on fox these days
is uh you know just pretend to be a
liberal
and uh and joe biden's press secretary
so that's what i did okay i'm sorry
i'm sorry that i did it but i thought it
would be a fun troll of the joe biden
campaign and obviously joe biden would
have no idea
because he doesn't know what planet he's
on these days
i gotta tell you though i tj ducklow i'm
a pretty weak
liberal spokesman because uh you know i
clearly had no answer to that question
and the reason is bret bear you gotta
give i mean this guy is so great this
guy is so great at his job he's
pretty much a straight shooter when it
comes to these things he says okay
you're saying that he was always clear
that he didn't oppose the travel ban
so was he for the travel ban was he for
it
and the answer is absolutely not how do
we know that we have joe biden on record
decrying trump's travel ban from china
when
it was instituted as hysterical
xenophobia
coronavirus emitted from china
a national emergency you know worldwide
alerts
the american people need to have a
prison who they can trust what he says
about it
that he is going to act rationally about
it
in moments like this this is where the
credibility of president
is most needed as he explains what we
should and should not do
this is no time for donald trump's
record of
hysteria xenophobia hysterical
xenophobia
no time for that no time by the way to
say it wasn't just joe biden at the same
time nancy pelosi
uh during the height of the rising
coronavirus
nancy pelosi goes to chinatown in san
francisco no mask
ton of people all around and says come
on down to chinatown
bill de blasio doing the same kind of
stuff in new york all of these liberals
were completely down playing the virus
trying to keep travel open with china
trying to get people out out in the open
they're still doing it with the blm
riots they're saying yeah go out and
write and all be together
but if you ever show up to anything
conservative then everyone's going to
die of coronavirus so it's
they have no answer whatsoever i do feel
a little bit a little bit sorry for mr
ducklow because
the campaign is only as good as the
candidate most of the time
okay and joe biden as a candidate is
completely failing he was asked a
question
about whether or not he's losing a step
or two whether he's
he loses his train of thought and what
does he do he says it's completely
ridiculous and while he's explaining why
he doesn't lose his train
train of thought he loses his train of
thought
just look at us okay just look at us
who seems to be in shape who's able to
move around
who's i mean this idea of you know
slow joe
i anyway i i shouldn't laugh about it
because uh
anyway donald trump uh just look at us
both watch us
and determine whether or not you think
uh um
i'm misleading anyone not you personally
but the public
you know look at me well you think i
would lose my
train of thought what do you think
people would say people have said that i
would lose my train of thought well just
because i saw a butterfly
what you mean like a monarch butterfly
one of those cute little
black and orange butterflies fluttering
all around you every which way kind of
blowing around in the wind and it's so
nice on a nice
light breezy day at the end of august
labor day weekend is a great time
i love labor day love american life what
were we talking about what are we
talking about again
what was that losing my train of thought
yeah so with that guy at the top of the
ticket
he's obviously not calling the shots and
so even with old moderate joe who's by
the way not moderate he's just an empty
suit who goes
like that butterfly whichever way the
wind blows the party is being led
by the radicals and the radicals hate
this country and the radicals don't
understand
this country most especially that very
poor
dishonest historian who did the new york
times's 1619 project we'll get to that
in one second
first oh gotta say goodbye to youtube
actually i
i sort of do have to say goodbye to
youtube in a larger sense
because if you're watching this show on
youtube you're probably watching this
on the daily wire youtube channel but
starting on september 28th
we are only going to be broadcasting the
show on youtube on the michael knowles
show
youtube channel only on that one because
i want to get all the clicks and i don't
want ben to get the clicks that's the
main no because
we just find it's a little bit easier
these days with big tech if we have the
shows on the show channel so make sure
you head on over to the michael knowles
show
youtube channel subscribe ring the bell
they might still unsubscribe you anyway
because there's a lot of shenanigans
going on these days
of the 2020 election but head on over
there anyway we'd appreciate it go over
there ring the bell right now we also
have a lot of extra content
they're beyond just the show i just took
a cognitive test that joe biden
is apparently taking that president
trump aced uh we can figure out whether
i'm a very stable genius like the
president or if my brain is full of
tapioca pudding like the democratic
nominee
subscribe to the channel ring the bell
head on over there
dailywire.com go become a member
go subscribe we'll be right back with a
lot more
in the mental absence of joe biden the
democratic party is being led by
anti-american radicals and
i can even get over their hatred of the
country or at least i can understand it
what's harder to get over and to
understand is how these people of
prominence on the left
don't even understand the words that
they're using the head of the 1619
project
that what's your name hannah jones
hannah jones over at the new york times
this
completely astroturf project where the
new york times deceptively used three
million dollars to try to promote it
even though
academic historians of on the left even
were saying it was completely
anti-historical the central thesis was
complete
bs now this is being taught as history
turns out this woman
who's come out against american
exceptionalism doesn't even know
what american exceptionalism means the
audio is a little hard to hear
this was on a 1619 project conversation
from campus reform
take a listen if this country
you know i don't think that we are an
exceptional nation i think that that's
ludicrous for any nation to make that
claim
and we certainly cannot make that claim
um
radiation founded on genocide and
chattel slavery and classes um
and gender discrimination i mean we are
not we had exceptional ideas
we are not exceptional nation we're not
an exceptional nation
we had exceptional ideas but we're not
exceptional exceptional exceptional she
doesn't know
the meaning of the word exceptional in
american exceptionalism what does
i think actually even even some
conservatives don't quite get it they
obviously get it a lot better than she
does
the idea that america is an exceptional
nation
is not merely a boast it is not saying
america's
just a super-duper greatest nation ever
that's not
all it's saying it's not making a
normative
claim about the country it's also making
just a purely descriptive positive
statement by the country which is
america is an exception to the general
rule of nations
why because it was founded and developed
in a different way
it's just different it's the exception
to the rule
what's the rule of nations well they
exist for a very long time and their
their origins go all the way back to the
murky foundations of history that are
often lost
to history this is true of the european
nations this is true of nations and
proto-nations in asia and the americas
and in africa but our country the united
states
was founded after the discovery of the
new world by these european settlers
who came over there who had distinct
ideas who broke
from certain general habits of how
nations are founded and that's why it's
exceptional because of america's unique
founding and development it has a unique
role and position in the world simple as
that you you can't deny that that's
merely an historical fact
but this gets to our broader point today
on the slogans
you got to get down to what the slogans
mean september 11th the anniversary of
the september 11th attacks was
just a few days ago top trend on twitter
that day was hashtag
never forget the second top trend was
hashtag all buildings matter
get it aha get it because i guess they
were they were making a point
that uh that because conservatives say
that all
lives matter in response to black lives
matter that when we talk about the
september 11th terrorist attacks
we need to say all buildings matter and
not talk about the september 11th
attacks the the blue check marks on the
left we're celebrating this hashtag
for making some point allegedly about
all lives matter but
like all slogans you gotta get down to
what the slogans mean you know you know
i hate slogans
i hate slogans because i hate ideology
because slogans like ideology can never
comprise and uh sum up the the totality
of
the human experience so you got to get
into what does it mean
well what does never forget me never
forget means
that the september 11th uh terrorist
attacks were horrific they were
traumatic
they changed in some ways american
policy they showed us our
vulnerabilities that we thought we
didn't have or we had
at least forgotten that we had since at
least 1941 and really even before that
because pearl harbor was not in the
continental united states 911 was pearl
harbor targeted
soldiers and sailors and 911 targeted
civilians so change things change the
nature of war
that's what it means what does all
buildings matter mean well what what
people who say that really mean is
yeah don't worry about 9 11. it wasn't
that big a deal it's you know it's just
like other attacks
black lives matter what does that mean
doesn't just mean black lives matter
what it means
is that america is systemically
oppressive and unjust against black
people that there's a scourge of cops in
this country who are racist hunting down
innocent black men who like lebron james
says can't even leave their home without
being hunted down
that's just not true that's just
demonstrably false you can
you can look at any of the facts of that
situation you see that is that is simply
not happening and then all lives matter
what does all lives matter mean
all life is sacred it kind of gets back
to the equality principle from the
declaration
that uh we hold these truths to be
self-evident all men are created equal
and endowed with certain unalienable
rights
by their creator which is true very much
in the american tradition
those things mean different things so
what do we like well yeah i like all
lives matter i don't like black lives
matter
don't like all buildings matter i do
like never forget there's nothing
hypocritical about saying that
you gotta go beyond the headline
sometimes the left will say well
you say you're pro-life but you don't
want a bunch of stupid welfare programs
so you're not really pro-life
well okay what do we mean by pro-life i
don't think you should be able to kill
babies in the womb
that's what i'm really saying when i say
i'm pro-life so you say you're pro-life
but you're for the death penalty
yes i think we should be able to execute
rapists and murderers and it's perfectly
legitimate for the state to have that
power as it always has
and also we shouldn't kill innocent
babies in the womb yep that's what i'm
saying
nothing hypocritical about that you just
have to go beyond
the slogan okay same goes for free
speech
as we were talking about what does free
speech mean does it mean you could
always just
say anything that you want no it's never
meant that anywhere
including and especially in the united
states for all those examples we we
listed earlier
and we know we know that the left's most
effective tool is language
that's how they manipulate the culture
with things like political correctness
here's a great example here's a great
example a group of black families just
bought 97 acres for a safe haven
in eastern georgia 19 black families
pulled their resources they purchased 97
acres of land
in eastern georgia as a safe space for
black families
and the real estate agent who did this
ashley scott declared to cnn
that quote i'm hoping that this will be
a thriving safe haven for people of
color
for black families in particular
okay that sounds so so nice right
doesn't that sound so good safe haven
that's so wonderful
now replace the race let's say uh 19
white families pooled their resources
and purchased 97 acres of land and said
i'm hoping this is a thriving safe haven
for white people for white families not
for black people they can't come in here
uh no i don't think we would like that
would we we'd say that's illegal that's
unconstitutional that
violates the civil rights act that
actually they're doing it right now
president trump has been touting this
new
this new executive order he has which
rescinds an obama-era rule called the
affh rule he keeps referring to as the
suburban lifestyle dream basically there
was this rule under obama
that said that the federal government
could seize a lot of power
from local communities in particular in
the suburbs and bring in a lot of
low-income housing
that was it was ostensibly the name of
racism really wasn't or anti-racism
it wasn't really that the whole reason
was to basically just shift reliable
democratic voters up into the suburbs
because the suburbs are purple so if you
can bring in more democratic voters
they'll shift
blue and they said this is all in the
name of racial equality so okay that's
that's good federal government can come
in take a ton of power away from local
communities
and all in the name of racial equality
but
but when black families purchase some
land and they say we don't want any
white people here that's totally fine
of course not it's just about the way
you look at it it's a way the language
is used
are we talking about a safe haven are we
talking about segregation meanwhile blm
rioters
are celebrating the attempted murder of
two cops
you you may have seen this video this
happened in i think this happened in
l.a while i was while i was away just
getting back
some thug walks up to two cops sitting
in a car totally unprovoked
and shoots the two cops then blm
activists
blocked the hospital where they were
supposed to be treated they blocked the
emergency room
because they wanted the cops to die take
a listen
all right it's hard to hear because you
gotta bleep so much of this guy but uh
he says yeah i hope they effing die who
are they
31 year old mother and a 24 year old man
think about this think about what think
about the metoo movement we're told that
if a man
treats a woman if a man propositions a
woman
that that's evil and awful if a man asks
a woman out on a date in an
inappropriate situation that's evil and
awful terrible
but a man can go shoot a 31 year old
mother totally fine if a man god forbid
beats a woman
beats his wife beats his girlfriend's
like the worst thing ever right but then
this man
goes up and shoots a 31 year old mother
and
prominent left-wing activists a blm
movement right which is
which has tormented our cities for
months now
says oh that's all well and good what
happened to that kind of stuff by the
way what happened to me too with cuties
cuties is sexually exploiting these
young girls all in the name of opposing
sexual exploitation of young girls okay
but they were sexually exploiting them
altering the metoo movement
what kind of a country celebrates this
stuff
what kind of a country what kind of
country do we want to have
what kind of country do we have i come
back from my vacation
hollywood is promoting pedo movies and
is literally burning to the ground we
haven't been
permitted to go outside in a very long
time
okay dr fauci dr fauci just came out
remember uh
remember 15 days to slow the spread i
think it was 187 days ago
you know what he says now he says now
we're gonna have to hunker down through
the fall and the winter
we're rounding the turn you see what's
happening you see the numbers are
plunging
i'm sorry but i have to disagree with
that because we're plateauing
at around forty thousand cases a day
and the deaths are around a thousand i
just think we need to hunker down and
get through this fall in winter because
it's not going to be easy
just gotta hunker down just gotta hunker
down for another
15 days 15 sorry i'm in 15 months sorry
i meant 15 years just hunkered down
forever says fauci
that's not science and that's not
self-government
and that's not life i loved going to
utah because i was basically free i
could kind of do whatever i want
my mask pretty much never left above my
nose often it was kind of
dangling down but no no one cared nobody
was
following these draconian measures not
rooted in science
and not rooted in philosophy not not
rooted in our best traditions
what kind of country do we want do we
want to be a country that has gone with
the wind and cop shows
or do we want to be a country that has
cuties because it looks like we can only
have one it looks like
looks like either you can have some of
the greatest movies ever made or you're
gonna have cuties are we
are we gonna be a country that hates
itself
that wants to burn it to the ground or
we want to be a country that wants to
build it up are we gonna be a country
that all lives together gets along
we're gonna be a country that segregates
ourselves what kind of country do we
want to be that's a question for
self-government
that's a question that forces us to use
our free speech proper speech
do we want to be a country ruled by 16
year olds and the spoiler at the
exploiters of 16 year olds and the
exploiters of 11 year olds
or do we want to be a country that is
governed by good people trying to do
good things what is that okay we can't
what what the right has done for many
decades is seed all of that ground and
say well we can't know what's right i
don't know
we'll just let the left have the only
positive definition of good or
bad and we'll just kind of pretend
everything's neutral and we'll sit back
and we won't do anything
well neutrality in times of great peril
and evil
is uh is perilous and evil itself
you've got you've got to have a content
here
free speech well what are we going to
say we have to know what we're going to
say and we have to know
what we're going to do that's our show
very pleased to be back with you all
i will see you tomorrow i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knoll show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2020.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen